hallo bei flugangst
bisher haben wir sehr viele positive
punkte geredet im thema digitalität wir
haben ganz viele aspekte der der ethik
in einer in den sitzungen behandelt und
auch in einzelnen videos die frage jetzt
ist nach den dunklen seiten nach den
schattenseiten der digitalität oder
digitalisierung hast du da ein paar
punkte die nur uns nennen kannst die wir
ins auge gefallen sind also wie ich auch
in meinem seminar versucht hatte zusagen
zu zeigen hängt die digitalität und die
digitalisierung wesentlich mit der
veränderten raum und zeit logik zusammen
ja das heißt wir sind nicht mehr
wirklich räumlich koexistenz sind wir
können uns in ziehen und auf so ein
niemandsland zurückziehen und diese
anonymität die nicht mehr gebunden ist
an die physikalische präsenz die kann
man natürlich auch missbrauchen
ich kann zum beispiel meine identität
verschleiern ich kann identität
vorgaukeln ich kann sie klauen und ich
kann im internet dinge tun die ich ihm
wirklich leben nicht tun könnte weil ich
dort physikalisch raum zeitlich verortet
bin und dingfest gemacht werden kann
jetzt der punkt aber irgendwie
identitäten fälschen das gab es ja schon
immer mit pässen aber das war würde ich
sagen raum zeitlich greifbarer mann war
konnte viel mehr körperlich auch gefasst
werden
man musste physisch präsent sein und
etwas vorgaukeln
und dass diese distanz zur physischen
realität im internet diese vermittlung
im internet die gibt uns mehr freiheiten
viel mehr sicherheiten auch um
moralische dinge zu tun würde ich sagen
dann ist ein weiterer punkt des internet
hat noch keine regeln und keine
ethischen vorgaben kann ethischen normen
ist es gewissermaßen der wilde westen
es ist noch nichts reglementiert
natürlich gelten gesetze aber es gibt
viele grauzonen das sind auch oft
angewandte gesetze gefahren von der
physikalischen welt ins digitale
übertragung genau das sind analogien
übertragungen völlig richtig wenn man
muss sich fragen sind diese
übertragungen angemessen ist dass
dieselbe ebene oder gibt es hier nicht
eine differenz die auch durch neue
ethische normen wir machen ein anderes
video noch dazu ein podcast irgendwie
abgedeckt werden müssen und ich glaube
diese unsicherheit und diese grauzonen
im internet die verleiten auch dazu um
moralische dinge zu tun
dann gibt es natürlich das problem der
sucht dass man abhängig wird von
verschiedenen inhalten geben uns auch
permanent präsentiert werden wir gerade
in so eine konsumenten haltung rein
lassen alles auf uns ein riesen- das
haben wir natürlich auch schon mit dem
fernseher dieses problem aber das
internet kann eben durch ein
gesteigertes angebot dieses problem noch
vergrößern
dann ist glaube ich ein großes problem
die fehlende körperlichkeit dass wir
auch wenn wir kommunizieren im internet
nicht mehr körperlich 9 oder
parallelbahn kommunizieren sie nur noch
sprachlich kombinieren oder durch images
oder so aber es findet eine gewisse
verkürzung stadt durch die
digitalisierung und die müssen wir
wieder kompensieren durch neue methoden
und da gibt es noch viel zu tun
ok danke jungs klar ein paar
verlinkungen haben sich reingehauen ins
video und ist seinem nächsten match ist